[Music]
hello Oh my buttons not working that's
okay little bit see that song slaps
though Tekken music is always godly and
they just released like all of their
music from all of eternity on Spotify by
the way I don't know that it's like a
Spotify playlist for it yes oh yeah it's
called I think Namco sounds and they
have all the techno music oh yeah um
hello everyone
it's Monday right happy Monday we're
starting off Monday with some good ass
[ __ ] um season 3 is live in an
effect and you know what else that means
the Athena has joined the battle David
and I were playing a couple ahead dad
Mac he's we're gonna keep playing for
you guys a little bit but my goal is to
learn more as a piano a little bit with
her but she's such a cool character I've
been watching you know players use her
yo in the FCC for me since she just
dropped it's really exciting I don't
have the greatest gift can play in the
world but we're gonna change that
hopefully with the help of you guys in
the chat that give us a penis yeah give
you all the tips I'm actually I realize
this is not a fighting game how dare I
make such a new mistake our good ol
fighting games can't be treated too soon
so yeah how's it going chat and hurt the
going save it how was your weekend my
weekend kick but to be honest was really
fun there's uh just caught beta stuff
going oh yeah freaking horrible and
there's a bunch of neat stuff and yes
prepping for her destiny shadow keep as
well and in the month so many games a
lot a lot of good games that everyone's
excited to play
all right let's get this screen of the
live now boom an optimal position for
camera please men fighting
alright so subpoena action without all
these fans to come both I'll be using
Safina hello Casper and grim gray and
Farhan and rental dead retro wolf Chohan
everybody woodshed mates me what's good
golly is amazing costumes she has actual
your Lords I like this business
yeah like you know follow the story of a
game right lot of dad issues Lewis says
I'm glad this character is back I
remember my tekken 7 days austin app and
i think she was also in like Tekken Tag
2 or something like everyone was in
Tekken Tag to you right yeah they had
everyone in seconds act you and they
have like weird variations school of
characters in second exactly there's
like Tiger ooh boss lady myspace already
decided already in the schedules of
cartel that's what I say it is how would
wear this outfit
shovel
Oh God I better kick to the yeah right
when I panic I'm like top kickers what I
know this game free it is most
definitely not free nor is the season
best but it should be cheap by now the
retail for the game itself yeah because
there's so much DLC and stuff now right
no Richie's in the chat
oh yeah she does dude she's been kicking
my ass all [ __ ] day my heart was
beatin if anybody knows what is her wall
combo I know every character like once I
get to the wall they have a start in
like two or three that will be like more
beneficial for the wall right no it's
I'm just going for the one and then one
plus to that which is the clients are
here a little like Tiger strike I don't
even know it I don't I don't know any
combos in this game I like I don't know
and I know some combos I know like your
typical like very basic like three
button basic combos right and then
pouring is the only one that I can kind
of go a little more but I can never
string combos together if you see any
comments that are straight here it's
biography right okay welcome back
how's my Korean back that's horrible I'm
player two sides not as bad now
Oh
juggle thoughts always make me feel
helpless I'm just like oh well game over
when that's my itself that one when
pursued it's a sober damaged I'm just
getting rekt and she's like she's
probably not even late to a meeting
totally pissed that like I don't know
she wants to get her coffee or something
and just like you know make some money
and I'm just like alright well first I
gotta do it
get out of here who's like why don't you
do famous oh yeah you're right back one
plus two and down three I do need to use
that more thank you thank you for the
reminder
ivory cut up down forward one two delay
one I can never get the delay ones right
is that the one with the star on the
notation just usually do
neutral neutral yeah I can I can never
get a neutral right dude
spider call attacks okay I'll try
they're hard to counter too
[Music]
Hey
- oh that's freaking cake though
you know not the club
oh I'm here store this games like $15
right now
but to be honest it's 15 bucks because
it's like all those characters you have
to buy a mouth this is three how much
the seasons 1 & 2 are they I think this
season passes are like 20 to 25 like
rape season right but you get like all
these figures all these characters up
here at the top these are sounds like
they're trying to be yeah they're making
the they're making the staff they're
integrating oh he's whipping out the
main character I can't if I can do
anything
oh the Ranger okay I can't I say no
don't remind me of all these movies me
killing me with the Rays are yeah well I
story mode with her maybe we could do
anything we wanted a as long as we're
playing Safina you guys I might test my
my online uh whenever I play online I
get absolutely nursery ground for my
scrub tactics don't work
out
[Music]
they made a lot of changes to moves
right they out of like new moves and I
did that's long I can't do that bird ron
carey let's see have a kick character
yeah when I would uh when I would play
with my cousins it would be like play
fighting some of us would always do the
la pose or you'd like bounce back and
forth and you have your hands violin hmm
trying to think realistically with the
game on sale and all the DLC you passes
[Music]
scary I'm not sure I don't know
Oh No your life I know jk jk ah that was
good that was fun game is wild the
slowdown is probably one of my lake top
five favorite things and all the
exciting good change that they added I
think like they didn't have this in the
old and it's neither of you hit each
other it like you're just like wins and
then goes back to normal
what a bit I gave missing the phone
Oh what button was that that was an
accident
oh gosh thanks for reminding me to rage
right by the lanes and save in
mccoullough over here
oh no good well okay here's the thing
I'm like barely hanging by and this
isn't even your main character when you
play as Oscar no no this is Phoenix
Dream will be no Oscar today oh I got it
I gotta make one I forgot to put my boss
lady outfit on I got it I gotta make one
that's why you're losing I don't use the
throws I usually do it for the two other
ones is this switch do when she gets
into her like stance that best scares
the living [ __ ] out of me
oh thanks
I love the classic costumes that wiring
has build because the first second I
played was Tekken 3 at least I so first
when I remember I played second to of my
cousins but I was like four years old so
all I would play us was like Roger Alex
or something and just like match that
one but I missed like half of it I
didn't realize there was no range on
that
yeah
in honor of my second flying cousins
we'd always just feel like just like any
time you do an anticlimactic but you
just go break some toast those are hard
to break in this game all right I'm just
gonna already
cuz like some characters have like you
have to hit one are you got that left it
to you
you think one plus two are you gonna
like put your left foot in the air and
then race the God's right hand and then
close your left eye it's all this crazy
oh I tried I tried to use your text
Oh
oh you love it you blocked it huh could
you oh I tried
oh I think it's cool d still get the
damage though somebody else that was
luck for me I guess
dangerous I'll scare it away every time
I see that blinking red I'm like dang I
was really clutch
[ __ ]
I don't like going on the right side Oh
Nate's gamers I do not know how to block
like never know how to block why block
in the game yeah it's so much fun I just
like picks up round one
fight
ah
oh that that width oh that was really
bad on my end
[Music]
jeez that claw oh yeah I've instead
wanna make him play second again you
already know
[Music]
oh my god what up Adrian Mutu
how goes it we just playing some tech
and check it out Safina
I need you guys it's help though I need
just not need your guys itself
Oh
round two I'm not I'm not going in
sports
hey time is my friend
now low kick
enjoy the low period I actually don't
know what her low parry combos I don't
know how to parry
it's just down board when someone hits
you low but if you miss a meet the
attacks of like I shouldn't have asked
that and I love I love for hangs like
air like it's just one kick but he does
so much good oh stop that
I'll do that Klaus so good
[Music]
oh dang bin is calling you Alex Ava he
says it looks like I need to get the run
back with David yeah yeah he's on the
weakest link let's uh let's go I want to
try a different assume I'm sucking place
whoring because I cannot play with
anyone else
I mean of my business dude I'm not
really well everyone is kind of a little
better now because with season three by
the way guys now it's an amazing time to
get into second that's one thing season
three introduced a bunch of new
characters well sorry one new character
but a bunch of new updates and patch
notes so characters got changed around
quite a bit
everyone got new a new move so that
already changed up changes up the game
tremendously so right now that really
good times the tournament scene is
thriving the Tekken world for is so
beasts I just got done watching
Technica mati in texas or ki t in texas
this past weekend Congrats to Jimmy Tran
for winning
Jimmy J Tran from norcombe actually so
bringing that w vaccine or iCal with him
but yeah everybody everybody should be
getting into this taking the world tour
finals are in Bangkok this year I want
to go I never been to Thailand but I
want to go oh this is my favorite stage
so we both seem to be on our work break
yeah call 1-800 can you not round - oh
snap
can the man said Maine Lily got buff
always good news
my sister Lily's place is named for
their own brand yeah exactly
[Music]
[Music]
why did I try to hit that sumo stop dude
that was
oh no way no way if you come back to
this I'm going to cry no no I did I want
I be so that you are gone dead it's
great that's how dead you are
so there's like scuttles away damn oh my
god
come on Waring I gonna get your your
business business or leisure come on man
the whole business yeah yeah I'm the
queen of astrology and take me to the
star that was those are good lines oh
well some good some good spice pouring
you need to calm down
No
round just enough damage
[Music]
is crazy
[Music]
oh you're selling my face just get rekt
dude oh my god Safina I'm like I've seen
her play she has so much cool stuff s I
don't even know how to do yet
[Music]
oh you just hop it on one stiletto do
you it's like physically impossible to
do that that fast the FINA is on another
level
, leads to America dang man how much
longer you want to keep just whooping me
until at first we had a game plan really
a couple yeah but you know how that goes
[Music]
I blocked it yes nice round to fight
but don't think that they can block it
[Music]
No
[Music]
humming - yeah it hurts though
hedgerows like a wolf son
Oh
[Music]
oh yeah you're right
I forgot tournament three rounds I was
just you know trying to take an
advantage over Dave a game but we should
it might be a game changer maybe yeah
it'll get like just right down to the
wire rounds one fight
[Music]
whoa that was terrifying very well
[Music]
is the closet anyway related to that
final boss epiphysis
cuz it's got like exact same
[Music]
my god
someone do the Heimlich on this man oh
that was a good oh man I was such a good
drive back to you I was like I know I
was like here's the comeback here we go
yes affinity here throwing there we go
there we go no perfect for you
[Music]
oh you think Warriors trying to play
around he's in a businessman battle me
know
[Music]
[Music]
oh yeah one-button supers now
something in the future that reach the
power my shoulder was too buff for that
that out of heat I gotta go read it art
for the language right now oh my god are
you kidding me chat where are you at how
are you sleeping right now
yeah oh my it's how we wrong what all
right that's it why I got a nice yeah
and it was just like no I have no energy
[Music]
[Music]
round two fight
Oh
oh dang
oh the characters switch it's only gonna
go downhill from here what you guys saw
that was the best I could possibly do I
can't do anything more than that I'm
done let's trade businesswoman suit
number two silver thing it's written in
the stars says Pedro a correct it isn't
either attending all right chat if you
could pick one character off of this
roster so much better and download the
most perfect way how to use them 100%
you'd be the best of that character you
know all the ins and outs which
character would it be that was your main
guys Salman who would you care
[Music]
I'm so I'm like you're like giving me
nightmares with like you're all what
just you're like hey so for you to came
out yeah she was like she hit me I'm on
slack and she's like hey David Safinaz
out do you want to just play some casual
matches like maybe I'll go you know you
can go easy on me I'm like alright for
sure let's change the round oh yeah yeah
but here I am getting Molly womp to you
just like completely destroyed honestly
like Athena looked super super dope and
which came out my eyes like man I wonder
you know how these users yeah and she's
actually been really good so I like it
but like I said I've been watching other
players play
and you know we look right there in the
bottom right is Athena join the battle
but yeah I've been watching other people
use this character I want to incorporate
right
negan though I remember when they
announced them last evil I was super hi
Ariane the guy was so it was so out of
left field
yeah I did the gameplay but the median
us.you stuff for me I'm like used to
very particular types of character
archetype see Megan had like an
interesting skill set wasn't bad
necessarily yeah he's pretty interesting
yeah like is I don't even remember what
it was maybe forward for us I think
that's a little an emu he had kind of
set up everything else for him yeah
which was really good but I may be fat
and train William for like 20 minutes
yeah oh it's on me all right cryo pyro
Molly womp
yeah I don't know if that's a real word
because that's the state that I've been
driven to after those games to where I
just completely made up a word I think
it's Molly Walker yeah Molly wah-wah-wah
yeah i just got rekted alright
officially at three rounds Thank You
Chad for reminding us
we're playing tournament style now David
you're just extending my
like I am
so just like oh they didn't hit by that
[Music]
[Music]
hello hello from Russia right back at
you sorry I can't pronounce your name
though yes sorry I do not understand
that alphabet
OLF broke that [ __ ] archangel said they
played Tekken since the first game you
should definitely be playing some Tekken
7 then because this is a legacy game
where all these characters are pretty
much very similar from iteration to
inner eight iteration so that knowledge
you have from like taking one through
six carries yeah I carry lower to 7 and
second sevens my first second no way it
is because I might say to you fighting
game hurt Mike good I'm so mad right now
I'm gonna take it all out in Savina if I
can
[Music]
[Music]
make me up nah all right you already
know what i'ma do
[Music]
- is
Oh
[Music]
I was like
[Music]
[Applause]
I won't survive this and now you've got
time to return the favor
oh you don't have to yet but you got
back on the bus to is super solid yeah
you're right every time I do it it
definitely hits do you know how safe it
is on hittin on block cuz then I might
have a better idea whack follow up with
it what the cause I seen [ __ ] I was like
I've no idea
Oh
[Music]
Oh
Oh
whoo
I
[Music]
yeah it fits me pretty far
oh my god Wow
whoo
no no no come on Oh God I get like so
chancing against it like the very end
[Music]
- no way they should have just been
first you
what
[Music]
out
no no no no no good what's not be right
about here first just yeah ya mean mugga
mugga moring so what's up look at her in
her antics oh my god so good
oh we got my boy Dom it's my college
friend in the chat just trying to come
talk smack on me the truth is that he's
uh oh and to in fantasy football what's
up
gonna roast you front of everyone get it
thanks for joining
[Music]
hey wait Bateman
all right rally and wonders of second
deck street fighter will ever be a thing
I really wanted to and I kind of thought
that the human Tekken 7 was like the
Lita
what's the indicator right so we'll see
but but Street Fighter at second I did
not like so much I played it I was hyped
for it I ordered it like as soon as that
came out college
[Music]
are we gonna do this Oh James Franco
let's go dolphins oh I am feel so sorry
for you if you are a Dolphins fan cheese
but that I'm not even gonna I'm not even
gonna bite pour salt into that wound
that's my condolences although I'm a
Raiders fan so we took a hard L yeah oh
no no no come on come on
how did I miss like 5k are you kidding
me yes a lie if you lie to me
oh it does huh though since you I should
be ashamed for doing that hey guys do
what you gotta do
oh my god do I don't I think you're
shaving like life off of my my age span
right life expectancy my life
Oh
finally Wow second is probably the best
among fighting games less exaggerating
buzzing stuff from full attacks I can't
tell that was sucking to turn out good
tech it is one of those funny games I I
love it a lot
Ivan played it really as much as I as I
should
oh wow Connor do
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
oh my I think you just didn't have the
same range finish Street Fighter cross
leg and weird gym system it did but it
had the cool thing where you can play
with like up a partner yeah don't trust
super fun I mean any any likes a game
right that's super fun tech attack
Oh No dang it
she was 2 equals $10 off
all day
Brett Oh
[Music]
haben
remember when wiring used to be broken
like second three and four yeah you just
get like them next to a wall or
something and I just like keep mashing
yeah exactly
kick everything I mean if you don't know
the gaps like myself yeah yeah me
getting kicked all day
Oh Oh she's like get down man someone
needed to help me with the with the low
ferry combo I don't know what it is I
might have an idea but
what
[Music]
no I did yes all right are we gonna do
this I know right what it was gonna be
[Music]
are in the business arms
[Music]
there's some really good rounds here
[Music]
Oh
No
[Music]
walk then moves are so satisfying while
standing moves are so satisfied yeah
oh no I tried to throw this white ball
rolling back I didn't mean anything I
don't want this fate
fight
[Music]
[Music]
yeah it's so good cuz you get a good
combo betcha so slow
[Music]
oh I almost stepped on your ankle
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh God
yes
all right how are we gonna do this I
know I'm late the fun out you got we got
all the time in the world
okay we're on one foot oh yeah that ring
dang it
[Music]
whoa okay that's really bad thing about
that oh that was good
relic for hurrying down bored 1/3 is his
new moon down forward down four one
three down four one three I think I know
one of his moves is uh it was right now
for our London left it's it's back up
three four that's this one those who are
you and then he ends up in the Flamingo
[Music]
but down for it I don't know I was
looking up the path oh yeah that'll hurt
although I guess I kind of baited you
with that way hey let me try this photo
real quick so you know we need you that
like your friends are like oh hey don't
move let me try something
eight
[Applause]
Oh what's sabe can I get a happy
birthday shout out happy very happy
birthday if it is your real birthday you
probably just said that just it's fine
just but we shout out everyone yeah
don't you've any ideas oh yeah
so
I hate this what you are now officially
like my little sister just like ya body
weight with found the weakness I wanna
do that's what you know she doesn't miss
Lilian she does this a little like oh
your guy is way over there
[Music]
hey let's get keep those feet yourself
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
your pre-order for we're dealin three
isn't coming to maybe contact your your
yeah I'm like so like all my energy just
went out laughing so hard in that last
round I'm like dead oh my god
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
yeah all right back one what's here
that's the move that is the way I
I know like you know Warren globe moves
and I can't sidestep I like well I mean
I can but like I can't
right
[Music]
this is the one fuzzy follow-up after
that fact one the first time I needed it
for that damage
[Music]
[Music]
oh I didn't do it one one reads me for
closer and that's kind of you right I
can't be oh yeah yeah
that is a good one see though because he
like gets two quick punches and then he
like it's a little stutter do you like
like legit like
[Music]
god I hate you so much
oh boy that's like the no mix-up mix-up
are am I gonna do the love that was good
that's one round one fight
already back at
[Music]
is the other character in YouTube no
warning is like an OG well I should know
he came in second three right yeah for
sure for sure but he was definitely not
in in second one
[Music]
[Applause]
Oh what happened
this one coal like linebacker on
[Music]
[Music]
ah
no I don't know when the strings in it's
it's hard to tell a man with them
because he always like just so many
moves that goes and the like those
flamingos and then you know left let me
go right and there's like his stance
which then there's a but it looks it
looks oh so he's like what it's like the
most important move no no I'm just
kidding okay it's called disrespect
sounds like yeah
Oh
yeah
[Music]
Wow
what
[Music]
[Music]
please snacks you might actually win
no thanks Oprah I'm gonna lose them out
what I mean maybe it might be
what's that Misha wasn't playing some
Tekken 7 today
then
[Music]
[Music]
how's it going the nice little baked
brown
[Music]
Stratego the grout
oh boy
[Music]
I might have been able on the bicycle on
the motorcycle I mean it's Heidi is all
the Finas cool stuff because all your
quick kicks hitter out of it really so
I'm like dang it I gotta rely on like
down board to every diet
I was like I just have to hold all this
and hope
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
yeah gotten the rally running for is
also safe with your character running
for ya
[Music]
[Music]
no my gret something
Dario's kicking me all damn day got
those electric no it's I can only do a
little bit of gin a little bit of law a
little bit of speed I actually what
Tekken 6 I really liked I really liked
Lars
yeah Lars was cool cuz he had some
really good moves yes Kurt I might go
lawyers after Shindo it helped me out
what's my wall combo I don't know what
it is I want to know I'm tired of giving
up this juicy wall damage just like you
do one one plus two when I land it
though I always yeah when I miss them
like what's C's ready Steve a fort try
to throw time to go regular throw that's
all I can do
Oh
[Music]
I think I've lost it yes round two fight
we
[Music]
oh I might be dead or I might have a
pixel think I did nothing shop as I want
you to uh three
[Music]
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
alors fight
dang it
Oh so far so far oh I know she's saying
what did I just do
who have I become this power season 3
these patches Steve the hoods off man
round 1 fight all right
[Music]
[Music]
all people round to fight oh I forgot
about that
one plus sewer like our buzzy buzzy
[Music]
oh I couldn't do it
round three fight
Oh tea love cheesy moves by the boxer
man frickin Havarti cheese it's like
let's all just want you to be for
punches you can't kick
although I like that I'd like to design
up speed words like you can't can't pick
you but he do we go to care just like he
can't kick but like if you press the
kick buttons it's like like it's you
you know I mean or not a Jew he just
like goes in a stance flicker I know you
got something called flickered you're
probably right hi everybody's head girl
how do you hit the dust frame and back
one all the time so I have a trick
hey when you hit back one I hold down
one and then I match - okay so as I hold
down one from hitting the one I'm just
mashing to with my ring finger and then
it comes out every time I don't know
what any of that means but I'm sure show
them when we get into that yeah let's do
it
there's a PR mode and second is there
Oh uni PlayStation if you're out of play
in VR mode I mean like what is it you
just like that would be wild I'll be
getting punched from all directions I
need a man it's it's pretty cool VR has
advanced it really is very much yes
button buffering that is what I do
what is it alright so here let me see it
the camera is kind of small so you can't
really see it I'm just gonna put it on
this one real quick so basically when I
do back one I like fold this down and
then I chop this and it does both some
so the button buffering is pretty great
for things like that I play on a
controller that's that's me alright
yes okay let's see if I can remember
anything
there's one set I'd like
[Music]
[Music]
there is a archangel uriel large man
give me some combos to remember that'll
be good I remember late there's
something yeah yes I'm pretty sick
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right
[Music]
yeah
red red red round three
whoa
[Music]
Oh
fight
[Music]
Oh
oh nice
I'll have to do the other one you get
breaking out no I object too much
[Music]
I'm gonna mass towards our last yeah
we're like last ten minutes I remember
there's a couple of names and Chad have
thrown in Lars is one of them I think I
want to say Brian was one too Brian is a
scary character without his mask I
always prefer the costumes he has a loop
of mask on goes you got a serial killer
face says it's all about King that's
true I can't play bingo game yeah I
tried playing his King but like the big
thing about King is like doing the grab
and then pressing those like 20 buttons
to get combinations in the grab right
and I can't do that but rolling death
cradle I was called that is highteeeee
takes like 80% damage
it's insane I got a new costume now boys
get out of here Brian can I hear you
prisoner
Oh
[Music]
if you got blue stuff I'm like hurt stop
[Music]
and what my back was turned step back
[Music]
round three fight
[Music]
[Music]
Oh No
Griffin Brian man she has like a power
crush type move in every stance she has
so yeah they all do different things
like her mantis one which is what I just
did is like it launches you love some of
the other ones she just have like some
arms like a spider one yeah
I heard noise I heard button animation
noise I'm like I'm like pressing these
ones trying to get his like Bing gun I'd
starve Everett - OH
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
prisoner Brian's just like he's like get
back in jail man so freaky yeah so Toki
throwing Logie you shake up the arcade
back in the day
it sounds like a joke but it's actually
true of people hated getting old for our
kids cause all out brawl like that's
what
that's worse than like calling their
momma or something I'm just like nah no
throws no nothing that is the number one
wrong yeah exactly
nothing is worse in fighting games and
getting thrown right just unplug the
whole thing it's like whoa what what you
just threw somebody hold up I've
actually heard some pretty scary stories
and they all were from people getting
thrown I'm like I don't know to be fair
oh you in the balls you know I think I
know how to be honest
Oh dad I was kind of mashing right there
at the end I was like what am I really
wait
but the other girl I can't throw key is
that is that a role here yeah right
only team can do the throwing here all
right
woman oh yeah
oh yeah Connor gets me great joy
yeah it's things like all about those
counters right like that's just that's
this thing not like this nah oh boy no
I'm dead I'm dead what what happened to
be down fighting oh my god alright
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
all right so we got time for a two out
of three lets you take your best kick
yeah all the marbles on the line
yeah I need you to cheer from eyes
Athena right now don't be salty Gatorade
you have one twice as much as I have
literally it says right up there I've
only won six times but what's 12 around
Steve don't be a salty bead over there
all right we're going back to business
come back business mode second don't be
scared don't know this some good ass
tagging has been like blowing up lately
internecine now is a great time to get
into it season through you just drive
with all the hotness all the passion
with season three hotness all anything
[Music]
and needed that follow-up
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so give that everyone wants a second
pack three you know the second tax use
and it's sample the fan base it's pretty
strong people still play in tournaments
tonight fight
I really can't round for Archangel
seconds act easel a lot of fun this it's
one of my favorites this was like
everyone's there it's a real nostalgia
trip too so if you like for example law
and Tekken 3 it's not martial law it's
forest law and there are people who like
really like Horace law and when you get
him it's acting you can do martial law
and force law which is cool that's like
[Music]
[Music]
oh yeah dude bet for sure and not bet
it's fake hazel you got me distracted
with that big dog
yeah that's my assist right there
Archangel Diocese officially over a team
prayers are long titoki all right so
that's one year right yes that's one me
yeah
can I stay in it and you will see fight
oh that's good I'm dead
oh my gosh Oh your Lord oh my god
[Music]
launcher is so bad
[Music]
what a blue devil that chat soon in late
zone could potentially be the last game
oh no oh my god do it really chat they
won't
oh my god the Chad needs you baby no but
I can read you there David thanks for
playing a little bit helping me learn
some latina action hope you guys enjoyed
I'm sorry my subpoenas not better than
that but for today it only need to be
better than David so it's all good happy
Monday you guys hope that you guys have
a great week we're gonna be here Monday
through Friday 11:00 a.m. Pacific time
so feel free to tune on in later in the
week if you can I'm not gonna wrap it up
with the stream today so thank you
everybody for tuning in and we will see
you guys next time
[Music]